what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
explaining the most enigmatic villainous
and ruggedly stylish character in the
story of demon slayer he is the final
demon boss the progenitor of all the
demons the smooth criminal and the
reason why the demon Slayers exist in
the first place I am of course talking
about Mouzon kyboot soo-ji and in this
video i will explain Mouzon secret
origins his incredible demonic powers
and his true intentions and motivations
i hope that having all of this
information right here in one place will
be useful to you and if you do find our
videos useful and you'd like to support
more of our work please consider
checking out our patreon link in the
description please be aware that this
video will contain manga spoilers we
will be talking about everything we know
so far about moves on his origins and
his powers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned we learn
about Musa when Sakon Jiro kodachi the
mentor of Tangier oh and Gil
tells Tangier oh that Mouzon is the
demon's final boss the progenitor of all
the demons and that he may be the only
one in the world who knows how to turn a
Zuko back into a human since that moment
tan Jiro sets his sights on finding
Mouzon and defeating him and the clash
between the two characters becomes
inevitable but what do we really know
about Musa he is one of the most
mysterious characters in the entire
series and as the main villain of Demon
Slayer he remains the driving force of
much of the plot however we do know some
important information about Mouzon
secret origins and 1,000 year old
backstories so let's talk about that
right now
parts of moosians backstory were finally
revealed in chapter 1 to 7 of the manga
Musa was born in the 8th century AD
which is over 1000 years before the
official beginning of the demon Slayers
story born during the Heian period of
Japanese history Mouzon was diagnosed
with a mysterious illness that was going
to kill him before he reached the age of
20 a generous and wise doctor was doing
his best to treat Musa
attempt to cure his disease we can infer
from this that Mouzon comes from a
wealthy family of high social standing
the way his home looks in Chapter one to
seven and the fact that he had a
state-of-the-art doctor for the time
visiting him personally tells us that
Musa was definitely not a commoner the
doctor was giving moves on a medicine
called the blue spider lily and it was
apparently made using the mythical blue
spider lily flow'r spider lily flowers
are normally red or white and this
mythical blue spider lily is considered
to be extremely rare but Mouzon grew
frustrated by the slow process of his
treatment and in a fit of rage he killed
the doctor who was treating him however
after killing the doctor he realized
that the medicine had actually been
working Moo's ons body became stronger
and he began exhibiting the demonic
power that he now possesses but the
medicine that the doctor had used on him
was experimental and it had not been
perfected yet despite defeating his
illness and gaining an incredibly strong
and virtually immortal body there were
also problems
Mulan's body could not tolerate the son
if he went out into the Sun his flesh
would burn and eventually disintegrate
this meant that Mouzon was only free to
move around at night Mouzon also
developed a need to consume human blood
and flesh in order to survive so he
essentially became a medieval Japanese
vampire he didn't actually mind this
aspect of his existence though Mouzon
clearly wasn't a very nice guy to begin
with judging by his treatment of his own
doctor so killing other people and
consuming them did not pose a problem
for him but the fact that he couldn't go
out in the Sun did greatly upset Mouzon
and he spent the next 1000 years trying
to find a way to conquer the Sun in
terms of personality Mouzon is a massive
egomaniac and his main goal in life is
achieving perfection however the fact
that he can't go out in the Sun is a
constant reminder that his demon body is
not perfect and that it has a blatant
flaw as I mentioned Mouzon quickly came
to regret killing his doctor because the
medicine that was used on him was very
experimental and so the doctor was the
only one who knew how to create this
medicine and where to find the blues
spider Lily now that the doctor was dead
Mouzon had no way of finding out how to
recreate the medicine let alone to
improve it in order to find a way to
conquer the Sun nevertheless moves on
continued to search for the blue spider
lily for the next 1000 years and on top
of that he began using his own blood to
create other demons now here's an
interesting thing
Mouzon had no desire to create demon
offspring but his goal was to keep
making demons until one day a demon
appeared with an immunity to the Sun
when he eventually learns that nez Zuko
became the first demon to somehow
conquer the Sun Mouzon goes wild he
proclaims that nez eco is the chosen
demon and he decides to concentrate all
of his efforts on finding Natsu coal and
consuming her Mouzon believes that once
he consumes Nezzer ko he too will gain
her ability to conquer the Sun and he
will finally become perfect after more
than 1,000 years of trying it is
important to remember that there are
massive gaps in moves ons backstory that
we just know nothing about the man has
been alive for over 1,000 years that's
one whole millennium and our knowledge
of what he has been doing for all that
time is extremely limited but we do know
that about 400 years before the
beginning of the series Musa was nearly
killed by the legendary breath of the
Sun user URI Chi su kakuni Mouzon barely
managed to escape with his life but the
experience of almost being killed after
spending most of his life thinking that
he is immortal had a traumatic effect on
moose on since encountering the breath
of the Sun user moose on has been
extremely careful and to this day he
continues to hide his presence from the
demon Slayers by shape-shifting into
various different people and pretending
to live life as a normal human in order
to keep the demon slayers off his scent
this would be a good time to mention
that Mouzon has the ability to
shape-shift he can change his appearance
to look like anything from an adult man
to a small boy or a beautiful woman
using this shape-shifting technique Musa
has been able to avoid detection by the
Demon Slayer core but there is one thing
that can still force moves on out of
hiding ever since first encountering the
legendary breath of the Sun user Mouzon
has been bent on destroying everyone and
everything associated with the breath of
the Sun
he considers the breath of the Sun to be
the only real threat to his existence
and this is why the Commodore family has
become the target of muezzins wrath the
Commodores have a direct connection to
the legendary breath of the Sun user as
the story progresses it is revealed that
tangelos ancestor Sumiyoshi knew the
breath of the Sun user directly
it appears that Sumiyoshi inherited the
hanafuda earrings from the breath of the
Sun user as well as the dance of the
fire-god which is of course a mysterious
breath style that has been passed on
from father to son within the comet of
family for generations
when Muhsin realizes the tundra wears
the same hanafuda earrings that the
breath of the sun user wore and when he
learns about the dance of the fire-god
which appears to be the style that is
the closest to the breath of the Sun
itself Mouzon decides that he has to
eliminate tangelo some people like the
former flame pillars in judo reign goku
believed that the dance of the fire-god
and the breath of the sun are actually
one in the same so it makes sense that
Mouzon would target anyone who is
associated with this style the breath of
the Sun is still the one breath style
that came the closest to actually
killing Mouzon so just by being who he
is and by inheriting what he had
inherited tan Jiro is seen as a major
threat to Musa it is worth noting that
nez Zuko is of course nonzero sister
another member of the Commodore family
so it is possible that her ability to
become the first demon to conquer the
Sun is also directly connected to the
breath of the Sun after all her family
has a direct connection to the legendary
breath of the Sun user and her family
has passed on the secrets of the breath
of the Sun for hundreds of years it is
quite possible that her direct
connection to the breath of the Sun is
the very thing that allowed nez Zuko to
conquer the Sun in the first place
but we still don't know for sure and
this is what we know about moves on so
far in terms of his secret origins and
his ultimate goal which is attaining the
perfect immortal body by finding a way
to conquer the Sun currently he believes
that his best bet is absorbing Nezzer
coal and his energy is focused on that
but now let's talk about moves ons
demonic powers of which there are many
there is one more big secret about moves
ons origin and identity that I still
haven't talked about but I will talk
about that in a little bit right now
let's
bosons demonic powers of which there are
many aside from the aforementioned
shape-shifting and the ability to turn
humans into demons by making them ingest
his blood Mouzon can also control how
strong the demons he creates are by
allowing him to take in more of his
blood but not everyone can handle having
a lot of moose ons blood in their system
and on one occasion at least Mouzon
injected a woman who annoyed him with so
much of his blood that her cells melted
and naturally she died like super died
Mouzon also has the fastest regenerative
abilities out of any demon he can
seemingly regenerate his entire body
including his whole head almost
instantly which makes it incredibly
difficult for anyone to actually defeat
him in battle
Muhsin also has a telepathic connection
with other demons he can read the minds
of the demons with whom he has shared
his blood and he can also communicate
with them telepathically and issue
orders he was even able to place a curse
on the demons that he has shared his
blood with so that if any of them
mentioned his name or reveal information
about him they will instantly die on top
of that we know that Mouzon possesses a
blood demon art that allows him to
create deadly objects out of his blood
and flesh such as spiked barbed wire and
he is also capable of absorbing other
beings into himself with all of these
powers Mouzon is a massive threat to any
demon slayer and it seems that the only
person who actually came close to
defeating him was the breath of the Sun
user now while we do know quite a few
things about Mouzon it is important to
note that what we do know is still
miniscule compared to the information
that is still hidden Mouzon has been
alive for over a thousand years so there
are many things about his extremely long
life that we still don't know anything
about likewise it is possible that moves
on possesses many other special demonic
powers and abilities that have yet to be
revealed it is important to keep these
facts in mind going forward but there is
one more crucial thing about Mouzon that
we learned in chapter 1 3 7 of the manga
Mouzon actually comes from the very same
family as booyah she Kika Gaia also
known as Hakata sama the leader of the
demon slayer core because of the fact
that a demon came out of their bloodline
the oubliette
family was cursed all of the children of
the family were born extremely weak and
none of them could live past the age of
30 unless they find a way to finally
kill moose on the booyah Shiki family is
doomed to die out completely and that is
why we Akata sama and all the members of
his family for nearly 100 generations
have been committed to destroying moose
on I hope we learned more about that we
ishiki family as the story goes on and
of course I want to know more about
moose on and how he became who he is
today please let me know what you guys
think do you like moose on as a villain
and what do you think will ultimately
happen to him do you think that he will
be defeated soon or do you think that
moose on still has a lot of tricks up
his sleeve and we are just scratching
the surface of his complex and ruthless
character let me know down in the
comments I always love hearing from you
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications feel free to follow
me on twitter and instagram at anime
outpour for all the latest anime news
and updates i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress on hell cruise stealers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith and fitty dalla beat and
also on epic thank you to all of ours
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
up up all other clans including Ingrid
ah a Lola madam madam AK and makoto-kun
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron only discord and to show our
gratitude your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us faze
Cowboys
[Music]
a space cup